you
hop in beasts all right yeah I think
that a puppy lover for 20 was a late
joiner for the last tournament so we
have a stacked a stacked hourly bold
arena this is great
okay so 30 call it 41 players in this
one on the fourth seed going into this
one third seed someone just dropped out
why'd you do that so I get paired with
the same guy in the last tournament
Jonah became yes I'll still try this
okay let's try a free okay so oh how
many times am I gonna fall for this
tactic I was ready to file for that
tactic that I felt this is the same guy
that I found for that tactic for I'm not
even speaking good English again I don't
know Bishop here you know on it they
were looking for more for more need to
watch over that square
okay
it's not fun what I'm doing here
their night isn't the greatest piece in
the world I think I want a sacrifice
yeah take down three pawns for the minor
piece keep that a knight boxed Oh rook
check watch out for the mates let's free
up some responsibilities here with my
rooks Oh brutal brutal okay yeah this
isn't good
Wow look at my time as well
all right I'm it oh well that's a bad
mouse slipper
okay another L to start hey that didn't
stop me from last time getting into
podium land maybe I just like chasing uh
I like chasing people that's all it is
that's all he likes to chase people
that's all okay we got a beefy one in
round two
okay it's the guy that took the cake
he took the cake last time
oh what a queen trade I need to get
developed all right we're gonna jump in
I need to box out that night
hmm and the king is a block hater
I want my bishop right here can I make
that happen
can I make that one happen
careful I'm on this hmm
I had a knight takes pawn don't want
this to open up rook checks lights crowd
control
they're in the think tank I don't want
to draw I want more alright let's let's
try another direction
where's my time open up another flank by
getting some material
alright let's take that Oh getting a
rook
oh there is I
determine I'll take it I needed that
that's a toughie that was a tough one
back-to-back to start a tournament geez
oh man
okay twelve teen is in first with eleven
and fire everybody up there has fire not
me though
hmm let's keep on going that's all you
could do wonderful advice I'm gonna try
that keep going that's all you could do
increase your your rating by a ton if
you follow that advice by picking up the
d6 pawn or not and have some guns here
two rooks watch out for discoveries no
no that's not discovery oh that's a
check though watch out for the pins it's
what I meant
where's my Nikon he's a little clueless
or is he alright let's just get back
some material to make it really simple
all right no back rancors I just want to
get rid of this Knight yeah that's the
way to do it now we got a flight Square
they're being sneaky they're trying to
catch me in a pre move who has fire I
got four I'm on page three twenty-one
minutes to go let's see who we get next
eighty seven players in this one oh man
my first chance at a four game three all
right we got dojo this should be four
advantage these dark squares right away
and I'll take out the night and let's
launch a jeep on not sure why didn't do
it like this keeping my king in the
middle let's go for an attack it's not
me that's what I was calculating it's
not mate but we got discoveries discover
checkmate back to tournament twenty is
in first twelve teen nine eight eight
eight eight I'm in sixth alrighty
whoo look at this beast the Ferrari is
in the house
process no no no let's hang on here this
isn't hyperbole you think you have time
you have time you have to pre move out
nice and easy that's the way to lose
upon just how I did it right then 94
Queen takes pawn yep
how already well I guess we're gonna try
for some Queen side play ooh
this guy's playing especially fast this
Knight needs to get out of there go away
you're nothing but trouble
let's get here
let's launch upon um Oh
let's take here the night house to take
yeah I had the bishop pair this guy's
underrated it's my it's my sense I feel
it oh I don't have two rooks on that I
was prepared to sack let's try it it's
not correct
a little gibbet ago maybe I get another
pond maybe all right I have some ponds
to work with Ron pond my king position
counts for something as well keep going
I could have also picked him up mmm if I
did this they were going to sack and
then take on c3 just want to push soon
very soon and they're down on time back
determine
yeah I guess part of the compensation
had to do with my king position a better
king position still in sixth that's how
you know it's a strong field when I was
just in sixth I got a I got a win and
I'm still in six call it now seventh so
long a lot of strong players up top many
that I have not played before this mean
this is one of them all right that was
my expendable Bishop the bad man break
down the dark squares
we're gonna go Queen side now let's put
a stop to this up on play against
LightSquared Bishop some and there we go
we get the dark square Bishop off Knight
here one day ooh
we trade
all right well I definitely still have
some compensation here
can i play Queen here I probably should
have covered that let's try for a queen
trade once more
Queen trade come on play for more okay
fun my knight on f6 hmm huh all right
oh the Queen's gonna enter right here or
is she yeah that would have been a
strong move I guess I'm gonna take
what's that move about
they're bluffing I got all the squares
covered I still have them all covered no
I don't dropping that pond now I'm
scared now I'm kind of scared oh boy
scary extra scary
can I just get a clean trade man that's
all I want
amen oh no got a night
huh
oh they got me mate oh I got appearing
again that was too fast of a pairing I
could have time turned that when all I
wanted was a queen trade give me the
Queen trade man that's all I wanted
why is my opponent not giving me what I
want
shame on that player beautiful English
shame on that player oh 14 minutes left
plenty of time Rock Cafe we give checks
no the Queen might take my night a very
bad pre move form very bad go back home
yes don't know how to fry me man thank
you
back to Turman 23 1717 less than 14 come
on get back on the horse less than 14 ah
this guy's going to give me a beating
what can I do against him
96 that'll scare
okay I guess we have a Budapest track
that pond down now all right well this
is a better start to then the positions
I've had before against him what am I
missing here hmm
I see it now
take and then take my bishop
[Music]
yeah trouble ooh hang on you see that
your bishops attacked uneasy for right
oh man I guess we're gonna exchange one
rook rook right here it's gonna hurt I
need to get some activity around the
bishop going all-in not even threatening
to get to the back rank clean here and
now starting to get to the back rank
Bishop here ho
sneaky interference out of
no it's totally MIT I should have played
Bishop here to have anything I don't
have anything I can't defend that me ah
man no good man no good Bishop to g6
there is no mate against our no defense
against g7 mm well you know it's it's
time for I have to go fishing I have to
go for cheap tricks
cheap tricks are the only way to victory
land and this one get ready for the
cheap tricks they're coming up cheap
tricks everybody better guard the H 2
and H 7 squares because I'm coming right
for him right now right now it's
happening get ready get ready
why not
that's actually working now that's
actually working
and g6 I have Queen g5 why did I say H 2
and H 7 I'm coming for you 16
how fours are tough to come by first is
30 there's 10 minutes and change left
who cats are awesome again
all right
[Music]
really can't get at age seven here but I
could push the night around let's put a
dent in the clean side
and I want my knight to arrive on d6
let's keep them there
and the queenside is really paralyzed
here Bishop takes pawn oh I didn't see
that still awkward for my opponent to
complete development
that Queen out of there she goes here
Bishop to have six Bishop to g2 I don't
want to take the night because I help
out the Queen side really in the think
tank really in the think tank
my queen is overloaded just then back
rancor
all right
you
ooh that was helpful and have much time
though on the rook
you
and no time back to tournament whoo I
got 1834 is in first twenty seven twenty
four twenty three twenty one up top all
with fire definitely need to get this
one here
let's just scoot right on by no there's
no fishing pole stuff from this line
only if it's there it's not there
let's jump in and I guess I get to
damage the structure know the bishop
could take that's right it's a very
weakening move
give me the H file I have the H file no
queenside I guess I got Queen side to
King b8 rook c8
laying on this wing cancel out that
night let's get rid of them
oh my goodness I just dropped my queen I
got this guy round though he's dangerous
he's a dangerous man
no he's too good he's still around
I'll try it's Forks I don't want him I
don't want him he needs to stay around
to be tricky
no trying to cash out
can't do that man I got this covered
get rid of their night attack they're
clean
check their clean again
let's give a check
still about a night I'm going to push
here
so scary
running out of gas
running out of gas
he's a dancing machine finally with a
fork in there down on time 34 31 6
minutes left where's the podium oh I
could try to get into podium land it's
gonna be tough look at these monsters up
here just look at him
ah this guy again how many beatings can
I handle
don't be me again
come on man
okay we got to stop b5 all right they
definitely have a very simple and
effective system
already
connect rooks for starters my knight
right here that's where he wants to be
there in the think tank I jerked them
here we go come on now Ron King
run towards the kingside I need your
help need your help
my vision needs to play
get out of there you're gonna go for a
perpetual
all right can I get a pond and clay I'm
gonna get rid of their night
I thought I was ready to drop upon there
they're really fast
[Music]
you
okay
holy cow
you
Oh
upon and I have a time though
you
time I guess I could just I'm lucky to
even get that one who lucky to get away
with a Dra
24:25 I got 24 25 26 31 whoo two more
games
one more game for sure monsters I love
it I love it
92 queenie to push another rook
let's go Queen side stay active with my
queen Bishop to b5 you check I'm on the
rook take free material this is leading
to mate they should resign they resigned
back determine what don't worry my 26
okay what is this opening what is this
gambits
is that what's happening gambits
queenside let's go Kings side mm-hmm
this is not correct what I'm doing let's
take here
where the mates his Bishop takes pawn
I'm fishing I am fishing take the bishop
and then give me
come on there's got to be something
juicy here where is it
dark squares hmm I need a flight square
no oh I just hung me in one this is such
a aah
this games so violent it's so violent
give me mate run each pond
yeah they don't like this guy I know
he's dangerous isn't he take it upon and
then glue him in here
careful maybe one make it to move King
yes
made on h8 back to tournament where we
yeah fifth I got 28 okay if I could get
this one what I I would get oh I can
maybe go fishing can maybe go fishing
against dr. cliffhanger castle
cliffhanger 40 seconds castle please I
need you to Castle castling is good you
know you want a console power of
suggestion there now following for a
power of suggestion tactics now no one
wants to see f3 it's for 24 seconds
they're going Queen side I resign I quit
I quit I can't win in flora moves I quit
okay we're gonna have to play this for
now and try and win this one not like in
the last tournament trying for a win it
wasn't there they can resign cliffhanger
what's the story with that clean move
get out of my house got no business
being there now I can't castle I don't
know how I feel about that no just open
it up because you're prepared to deal
with the opening up of the position sad
move both rooks that way you can't
castle either way very good strategy I
should try that more often Castle by
hand it's the way forward watch out for
Queen h6 Knight moves Queen h6 ideas how
about we look for a mate on b2 supreme
of it they're down in time back to
tournament whoo a tough one a very good
one I'm in sixth with 28 43 34 34 any
flawless victories
nothing
probably the best result is this one
here 12 team 12 teen had a lot of games
in
No everybody with their fair share of
speed bumps expected tough tough tough
43 34 34 33 28 is where I finished I had
a Ferrari
I had a Ferrari all right let's see page
2 126 in this one total 3 4 5
okay 13 pages here
and am blue chicken gambit love it
yeah that's everybody already to 125 of
you good games all
you
[Music]